bonsoir nadège le projet du garde des
sceaux donc adopté en première lecture
absolument et avec 342 voix pour cent 5
contre et 96 abstentions alors c'est un
texte un qui est censé rétablir la
confiance entre les français et
l'institution judiciaire je vous propose
à ce sujet d' écouter la réaction de
députés que l'on a pu interroger à la
sortie des débats c'est vraiment une
très petite loi mais alors très très
très petit c'est parce qu'il va
révolutionner la justice dans notre pays
c'est à dire donner davantage de moyens
pour le fonctionnement de notre justice
parce que c'est déjà tout ça le vrai
sujet alors effectivement les avocats
sont davantage protégés c'est bien les
procédures seront un peu plus courte de
façon à éviter parfois des abus tout ça
c'est cet athée tout ça c'est
intéressant
enfin franchement c'est pas c'est pas ça
qui va révolutionner l'action de la
justice dans notre pays il ya des choses
qu'on peut pas laisser passer
les amendements déposés par le
gouvernement pendant la manifestation du
19 mai par exemple c'est des choses
n'ont en fait pas une loi sous la
pression d'une manifestation
donc il ya une déception on peut pas
demander à filmer un jugement nous sur
le coup on s'était dit c'est une bonne
idée le peuple fait la loi que des
jugements soient filmés le peuple peu
pour en faire une émission de télévision
prennent avec ce projet de loi a été
amendée pour répondre à la colère des
forces de l'ordre après les meurtres de
deux policiers absolument stéphanie un
amendement prévoit d'ailleurs de passer
de 22 ans à 30 la peine de sûreté pour
les condamnés à la prison à perpétuité
pour un crime commis contre un policier
ou un gendarme autres dispositions de ce
projet de loi la fin des rappels à la
loi jugée inefficace ou encore la
limitation des réductions de peine pour
les agresseurs des membres des forces de
l'ordre alors pour le grand public l'une
des dispositions phare de ce projet
c'est la possibilité de filmer les
audiences d'un procès d'autres
propositions visent par ailleurs à
améliorer les procédures pénales comme
par exemple la limitation de la durée
des enquêtes préliminaires ou encore le
renforcement de la présomption
d'innocence ou encore du secret de la
défense ce projet de loi devrait être
examiné au sénat ce sera courant
septembre